Religion in many ways gives you
answers right now. Yeah. Without the,
to sort of to the research
it or to go on the frontier.
The lack of education and the lack
of a lack of curiosity about it.
It's one of the scariest things
about new generations of kids, right?
Like when the new
generations are coming up,
if they know less than
the generation before,
that's when we really start to freak out.
That would be a problem.
Although I have good confidence
in the 30 and under gender.
Does that millennial,
I will be have to be,
I think millennials have only ever
known the Internet and devices.
So what would you say recent,
but my son is a millennial and he's like,
my kids are millennials so they're
twentyish so 30 is a little old.
So 25 and under I think
are the millennials. Yeah.
But 30 when they were 10 the
Internet was around. I know,
but they need a different marketing terms
so you can market to them differently.
Yeah. So to me, I would put them in the
same bin just as you were thinking there.
But,
but they,
they have a different relationship
to science and technology.
Of course they're not, they don't
fear the science or the technology.
They embrace it because it has shaped
the civilization that is enabled their
social life. It has. But through this,
like one of the things that I tweeted,
I think it was from scientific American
yesterday, maybe it was yesterday, that,
uh,
it's a little bit misleading,
but one of the things they said is only
64% of millennials have a strong belief.
These things, these coasters
are terrible. They look great.
But then things stick to the
bottles are made of a metal,
a metal coaster. Yeah. See what
the hell is that sticks? Yeah.
That's the issue sticks
when it gets moisture,
you know about this. We flip this
over and he tip it over and then it,
what happens on that? They never
did that. What? Datastay yeah. Oh,
because of the pressure. The
air pressure on it. Okay.
But don't do it.
I don't trust your science.
Your objective truth.
64% of what of millennials are not,
uh, are only 64% are convinced
that the world is a ball.
The world is a circle that [inaudible] us.
What is it a spheroid?
Is that what it's called? Oblique. I'd
like to see how that question exactly.
Because if they know that we are ablate
and the thing is asking, is Earth a ball?
They'll say, no, we're an ablate ball or
a slightly wider below the equator than,
uh,
than at the equator.
So we're a pear shaped oblate spheroid
but it's not a pair that you would find
normally if you found that period.
But like this is fucking pair
that's shaped like a ball. So the,
these distinctions,
these differences in measurements are
so small that if you found it on the
ground, you would say, this is a perfect
sphere. Right? Let me tell you how,
how good a sphere it is. Right.
All right. Do you ever see the,
the school room Globes,
the Geographic Globes,
and you rub your finger over in Nepal and
you get the th the Himalaya? Yeah. Yeah.
And you get the Rockies. He said, Ooh,
that is a gross exaggeration of reality.
Yes.
Do you realize if you took earth
with all of its mountains, valleys,
and hills and rep and shrunk it
down to the size of a cue ball,
he'll be smoother than any cue ball.
Every machine?
Yes.
Think about it. Why? I think, think about
this Joe. Really. Joe Rys, go chill.
Listen to me. You Ready? Okay. Uh, do you
know the deepest part of Earth's crust?
No. The Marianas trench off the coast
of the Philippines in the Pacific Ocean.
That's the deepest, deepest white it
six miles down. Okay. Oh, okay. So,
okay. Sorry. No, no.
Just access to the deepest
part of Earth's crust.
The lowest point on her surface.
The Marianas trench right off
the coast of the Philippines.
The highest point on earth surface.
The tip of a k one k two k one
or k two which one is Japan?
I think it's k one.
Why would you name the tallest peak?
K Two it's good to point. I'm just right.
I'm not a mountain climber, but I'm,
I'm just thinking k one k with the,
it's the Himalayan mountains in Nepal.
Okay. Isn't it in Nepal? I'm
thinking it is. Yeah. Yeah. Okay,
so now let's say how high up is that?
It was 28,000 feet,
so it's like five miles up.
Okay. Right. The distance
between the lowest point on earth surface
and the highest point on earth surface
is 11 miles.
That's here to the comedy store.
That is less than the length of Manhattan.
Whoa.
Yet we are 8,000 miles in diameter
and those two points are very
far separated from one another.
If you are cosmetic giant and you came
up to earth and you rubbed your finger
over earth's surface,
it would feel as smooth
as a cue ball to you. Wow.
In fact, in this, in this book, I have
a whole chapter called on being round,
which is all about,
this is all about our perception
of what is round and what is not.
I had asked you to debate one of them flat
earth guys. No, I don't. I can't. I know,
I know. We talked about it and
we're going to have him on Skype,
not what we do is,
and I think this is a diabolical plot
so that the next time we can ship people
on mass into orbit,
they all want to be the first
in line because they know
we're going to send them.
So if they can see the round earth,
they're going to be the first ones in
space just so they can stop annoying the
rest of them. I don't think you're
correct. I don't think you're correct,
but everything is a diabolical plot.
I do have people that have met
that don't believe because they,
the problem with youtube videos is that
it's a problem with a lot of things,
but one of the things
about being unchecked,
why you are discussing things is you
can say things, you can use big words,
you can sound articulate and smooth and
you can do it in a very professional
looking manner or do it
passionately. Yes, passionately,
convincingly charismatically and you,
you're unchecked.
But if you did that in front of an expert
and you showed them that along the way,
they go stop. That's not true.
Stop this. Not what works. Right?
Let me show you why this is incorrect.
Let me show you how you could prove that
this is incorrect. Objective truths,
but this is not happening.
Render your argument invalid so people
don't have any education and then they
watch one of these youtube clips.
They start actually believing that this
stuff makes sense because it's unchecked.
And I would say it's not about
whether they've had education,
it's about whether the education they had
teaches them skepticism of information
and teaching them how to inquire.
You realize it's just as intellectually
lazy to believe everything you see as it
is to deny everything you see.
Yes.
Why should someone know automatically
that earth isn't flat yet?
I tell them in the next breath that the
entire universe was once a small as a
marble,
right?
Both of those sound equally preposterous
except one has evidence to back it and
the other does not.
And very strong scientific theoretical
and experimental underpinnings.
So when you are trained to inquire,
you don't either believe everything
outright or reject everything out, right?
You're trained to ask questions.
You trained to probe deeper than the
layer of information that comes to you.
That's what should be taught in school.
And it's not,
they give you a book and say,
learn this and you'll get tested on it.
And then when you're done,
learn this well is it also there's a
problem with being inexorably connected to
your first belief to when you have
an idea and it's in your head,
it's very difficult for people to shake
that idea and they start arguing that
idea,
that idea becomes a part of their identity
and they dig their heels in deeper
when an opposing view is presented to
connect themselves to these ideas, right?
It's, it is who they are.
Right? Right. And so I,
I try not to base my character profile
on something that is not yet verified as
objective truth.
And this is a very good thing to do.
It's one of the reasons why I
don't have tattoos on my body. Oh,
holdings go. It's stretching my face.
Go on.
Uh,
one of the reasons is there's
nothing I am so sure about that.
I want to put it in Delhi on my
skin with, no, no, that's not,
let me say it differently.
There's nothing I value in my mind,
body,
and soul so much in this moment that I
want to indelibly etched it on my skin
cause I want to leave room for me to
have a possibly more enlightening thought
later.